This problem can be solved by
setting up an algebraic proportion.
The diet claims that you can
lose ten pounds in seven days.
This can be expressed as a rate like
this, ten pounds over seven days.
You can also write a rate for the amount
of weight that you want to lose,
even though we don't have
the number of days yet.
We'll use 25 as the numerator and
set the number of days equal to X.
So we have two rates here, we can use
a proportion to solve this problem now.
An algebraic proportion has two rates or
ratios in fraction forms
that equal to each other.
So I have moved things
around a little bit and
set these two rates equal to each other.
So for this problem,
ten over seven is equal to 25 over x.
Notice that I have placed the pounds
in the numerator of both rates and
the days in the denominator for
both rates.
It is important when setting up
a proportion that you place the same
units in the numerator and
the denominator.